HBO has just put out a second Game of Thrones
Season 6 trailer, and some short clips from
the first few episodes.
There’s some crazy new stuff here, so let’s
have a quick look.
Again, the trailer starts at the Wall, with
the body of Jon Snow.
Davos and Ghost and some loyal Night’s Watchmen
seem to be defending Jon’s body from the
Watchmen who killed him – including Alliser
Thorne, Bowen Marsh, and everyone’s favourite
black brother, Olly.
Melisandre’s around as well, so again this
will probably eventually somehow lead to the
resurrection of Jon.
Whether this’ll involve sacrifice or fire
or blood or Ghost or white walkers we don’t
yet know for sure.
We also see more of Bastardbowl, the big battle
fought between the Boltons and the wildlings
and the north just outside Winterfell.
You can see the heraldry of Houses Hornwood
and Mormont, and the Umbers with the Boltons,
and Davos is here, beneath a Stark banner.
We also see Tormund, and Ramsay, and the big
friendly giant Wun Wun bursting through what
looks to be the gates of Winterfell, and also
that horse leading the cavalry charge might
be Jon’s.
There’s a clip of Theon and Sansa running
through the snow to escape the Boltons, and
we later see Sansa at the battlefield wearing
Stark clothes.
She talks about the people who took from her,
over shots of Ramsay, and of what looks to
be a Frey wedding, with Lord Walder and Lannister
soldiers.
This could be where Sansa and the Starks take
revenge, a Red Wedding 2.0, where Freys and
Lannisters are slaughtered to avenge Robb
and Cat and Ned.
This could involve the Blackfish, the brotherhood
without banners, maybe Arya if she crosses
the narrow sea…
We don’t really know how it’ll go down
but one way or another the Freys will finally
get what’s coming to em.
In Braavos, Arya’s still in the House of
Black and White with the Faceless Men, still
blind, though she seems to get her sight back
at some point – here she’s sparring, getting
slapped up by the Waif, and then she’s told
she’s on her second and last chance by Jaqen
H’ghar, or rather, by someone who’s wearing
Jaqen’s face – remember, last season,
someone with Jaqen’s face took poison and
died.
So, remember that any Faceless Man can wear
any face, they don’t really have personal
identities, they are no one – which is what
they’re trying to make Arya.
But it doesn’t look like Arya is willing
to let go of who she is.
Further east, in Meereen, Tyrion, Varys, Missandei
and Grey Worm try to hold things together.
It looks like they’re challenged by the
Great Masters, the original rulers of Meereen,
and the Sons of the Harpy are still a threat,
and we meet a new player, apparently called
Kinvara – a red priestess like Melisandre.
She’s looking pretty pleased with herself
here so it’ll be really cool to see what
this new red woman brings to the table.
We also see Tyrion talking about dragons not
liking captivity, and then he sees Rhaegal
and Viserion for himself in the Great Pyramid
basement.
So we can probably expect the dragons to finally
be let loose sometime soon.
We see Daenerys in Vaes Dothrak, the sacred
city of the Dothraki.
She’s stripped and downtrodden – has her
power and prestige taken away from her.
These women are probably the dosh khaleen,
the ex-wives of khals who in Dothraki culture
are expected to live in Vaes Dothrak.
Jorah’s coming to try to and save her, and
he’s bringing his deadly greyscale with
him, but Dany’s salvation will probably
be Drogon, so Dany can answer the disrespect
of the Dothraki with fire and blood.
On the Iron Islands we get a bit of a Greyjoy
family reunion – Theon meets with Asha – or
Yara – and uncle Euron turns up to kill
his brother Balon.
And it’s starting to look like Asha is taking
on the role of Victarion from the books, meaning
after the kingsmoot, she may be sailing east,
to Meereen to meet Daenerys – the evidence
is that this girl Asha is making out with
looks like a slave from Volantis – and the
only reason Asha’d be in Volantis would
be as a pit stop to Meereen.
So maybe Asha will meet the dragon queen.
In King’s Landing, Cersei Lannister is mad
as hell.
Jaime has brought back the body of Myrcella,
leaving Tommen her only surviving child, and
the sparrows still have Margaery and Loras
Tyrell.
Cersei sends Jaime up against the High Sparrow,
and shit gets real quick – a Tyrell army
approaches the Great Sept, and Lord Mace wears
a funny hat, Robert Strong is let loose on
the sparrows, and there is blood.
At some point it looks like Jaime goes to
the riverlands, which is something that happens
in the books.
Brienne and Podrick also seem to be there,
and Pod is jumped by Bronn.
With Jaime, Brienne and Pod all in the riverlands,
it might be that they take part in the Stark
vengeance at the Frey wedding, they might
also get involved with Lady Stoneheart if
she turns up.
Bran Stark is beyond the Wall with Bloodraven,
aka Brynden, aka the three-eyed crow, who
is giving Bran visions of the past including
this one of the fight at the Tower of Joy,
between three of Aerys Targaryen’s kingsguard
and seven of Ned Stark’s men.
This guy here may well be the legendary Arthur
Dayne, while the bloke who gets shishkebabed
must be one of Ned’s guys.
But again, the really cool thing about this
scene is that we may get to see Ned’s sister
Lyanna, and the true parentage of Jon Snow.
We also see Meera Reed, who apparently is
still hanging around in Bloodraven’s cave,
with Hodor, and Jojen, assuming he hasn’t
been eaten by Bran.
And finally we see the white walkers, striding
through fire, riding four horses, with Davos
describing the war to come.
At this point the walkers’ve really got
two places left to strike – Bloodraven’s
cave, and the Wall itself.
So that’s the second trailer – conflict
at Castle Black, huge battle in the north
and maybe vengeance for the Starks, tension
rising in the House of Black and White, new
players in Meereen, Dany against the dosh
khaleen, Greyjoys converging on Pyke with
Asha sailing east, shit hitting the fan in
King’s Landing, with sparrows and Tyrells
and Bobby Strong fighting, and also stuff
in the riverlands, Bran on the weirwood net,
Tower of Joy, Meera Jojen Hodor, and the Others,
the white walkers, on the attack.
This season’s gonna be crazy, so if you’d
like to know more, check out our videos on
Arya, Dany, greyscale, Euron, Robert Strong,
Jojen’s fate, Jon’s resurrection and much
much more.
Please like and subscribe, and see you next
time.
This video was made with the support of Patrons
on Patreon, including Ashley Whitlock, Casey
Koons, KingslayerJamie, Edmund Dantes, Steinar
V, Simen Kristoffer Frogner, Shamma Abdalla,
Yasuna Murakami, Ruggero, Philippe, Dan chang,
Neil Renken, Jakob Knudsen, Yenyo Pal, Nils,
Kostek, MugChip, Erik, Jodi T., Team Garcia,
and Albert Bork.
Thanks guys.